oi
vamos dar um e de criança porque o que
eu tenho pra falar pra vocês é algo um
pouco triste então a gente começa alegre
para encarar a realidade
oi
ah se eu dissesse perguntasse aqui se
alguém conhece uma criança de três anos
chamada ailan kudrin possivelmente uma
maciça maioria não saberá quem é
agora se eu mudar a pergunta aí vocês
saberão a resposta se eu disser alguém
se lembra de um menino que foi
encontrado morto de três anos de idade
num processo de imigração extremamente
complicado numa das praias da turquia
muita gente já sabe quem é mas se eu na
verdade mostrar a foto aí a gente vai
ter certeza de quem é essa foto ela
rodou o mundo inteiro levantou protestos
provocou reflexos líderes e governantes
artistas fizeram várias representações
chamaram mundo de vergonhoso maléfico
tenebroso açougue de carne de criança e
as pessoas refletiram esse protesto
inclusive chegou a fazer provocar uma
mudança de postura na premier league
mann
todavia se eu disser pra vocês que esse
fato se multiplica um milhão de vezes
todos os dias de formas diferentes e que
não teve toda essa vastidão vocês
ficaram assustados
nós fomos o primeiro órgão do ministério
público do trabalho a investigá à
exploração de crianças e adolescentes
aqui na paraíba mas rodamos o brasil
inteiro treinando outros colegas
o resultado foi isso essa menina de 10
anos
ela vendia o corpo por uma recarga de
celular
de 20 reais essa foi detectada numa das
nossas todas essas fotos são reais e nós
do ministério público
essa foi encontrada numa blair de um
caminhão também vendendo o seu corpo por
sexo
16 anos
eu também encontrei na edson ramalho das
principais avenidas da capital uma
travesti de 13 anos de idade a gente
retirou essa menina
essa menina é travesti e na outra semana
ela voltou mas já vou falar nela pronto
apareceu no brasil cerca de 2
aliás perdão no mundo cerca de duas
milhões de crianças são exploradas
sexualmente
nós temos só no brasil o percentual de
no mínimo 200 mil pessoas
aí você pode estar pensando não isto só
acontece em países que estão em situação
de pobreza ou de vulnerabilidade social
eu não encontraria tal situação nos
estados unidos e se eu sei que você está
enganado
o que nós detectamos tráfico interno e
internacional de crianças
para fim de exploração sexual com o
destino estados unidos da américa com
destino europa do leste europeu
nós temos uma infinidade de casos de
exploração sexual de crianças e
adolescentes
e aí fica uma grande pergunta
imaginemos agora um fazendeiro ele pega
as sementes prepara-se para fertilizar e
depois colhe no final
vocês acham que essa coleta será boa se
a semente não for bem cuidada é
exatamente o que o planeta terra faz com
as crianças que aqui vivem
nós não temos crianças bem cuidadas
nós temos crianças e adolescentes que
estão numa condição social melhor e tem
acesso a mais coisas mas nós fomos falar
de políticas públicas maciçamente os
países não tratam bem das crianças e
adolescentes
aí nomeadamente alguns claro mas em
regra geral eu diria que a situação da
criança e do adolescente hoje no mundo é
bastante preocupante
aí eu fiquei pensando uma vez no
primeiro caso que gerou toda essa
repercussão eu fui a uma cidadezinha
aqui na paraíba porque dez autoridades
públicas estavam envolvidas em situação
de exploração sexual de crianças e
adolescentes 10 secretários municipais e
outras autoridades segundo escalão que
inclusive fazia os programas com meninas
de 12 13 anos com os carros oficiais do
município
é o brasil só no brasil
cidade da guatemala crianças são
exploradas sexualmente em prostíbulos e
quando eu fui esta cidade investigar
exatamente essas autoridades uma um
toque na minha alma mudou a história da
minha vida eu fui ouvir uma adolescente
que na ocasião já estava com 16 mas
começou esse problema com 12 13 anos
inclusive envolvido com essa máfia
pública
e quando eu olhei diretamente nos olhos
dela
eu não vi um espírito nenhuma alma
eu não conseguia ver brilho algum nos
olhos ela inclusive pra mim não eu fazia
porque eu queria eu não vi nenhuma
modificação durante todo o depoimento no
semblante daquele ser humano eu disse
não a vida ali há um corpo mas eu acho
que a alma está no estado de
adormecimento grande quanto tempo vai
durar esse adormecimento e aí eu disse
eu me lembrei da minha infância que por
um lado foi muito bom eu tive um lar
saudável
meus pais eram classe média nada me
faltou nem de afeto nem materialmente
condições para estudar nada mas eu era
uma pessoa diferente
eu na verdade sempre fui muito nerd
muito futurista e aí eu não conseguia
dialogar com os meninos da minha idade
primeiro eu era péssimo de futebol que é
um elemento de inclusão social
eu não tenho carro no pé e tem um pé de
pato
então estava bola pra lhe ia para lá eu
só fiz um gol na história da minha vida
eu acho que foi por engano
você imagina um menino não ser chamado
para participar de atividades no colégio
e não entender por que ser chamado chato
ou colégio até pelas mães dos
coleguinhas
isso chocou e ficou mandou
aí eu pensei que aquela menina e aquela
outra travesti com 13 anos de idade
encontrada numa das principais avenidas
da cidade
se isso que eu sofri é tão pouco de anti
da dor daquelas outras crianças
eu preciso fazer alguma coisa não como
autoridade pública não como cidadão mas
acima de tudo como ser humano é muito
mais fácil a gente apontar o dedo pra
quem não faz a gente primeiro deve
apontar o dedo para o espelho para saber
o que a gente faz
e aí eu peguei algumas frases que o
colhi inquéritos de crianças entre 11 e
15 ou 16 anos crianças e adolescentes
quando eu engravidei esta foi aquela
menina do estado interior
bati na minha barriga com o cabo da faca
já tentei me matar por duas vezes ela me
disse
sem um sorriso sem uma tristeza uma
revolta nada simplesmente esse é da
menina travesti de 11 anos 10 11 anos
que foi encontrada na general na edson
ramalho que a gente levou para casa seu
novo conselho tutelar e ela voltou todas
as vezes pra esse meio de uso humano ela
disse
meus pais não me aceitam me botaram na
rua
tive que me virar com prostituição
houve aqui pertinho de você
direto à sua janela quando eu escolhi um
tema para expor a minha palestra
eu disse que seria um dia uma criança me
tocou
eu espero que você também se deixe tocar
por uma criança
outra frase que me chocou bastante foi
uma que estava aqui foi junto com a
polícia rodoviária federal
capturada na boleia tá capturados na
margem da br uma rodovia federal uma
auto estrada e ela disse eu faço sexo
por qualquer coisa
até quando alguém recarrega no celular
com 20 reais inclusive na foto ela está
com o celular na mão falando esse
depoimento foram todos os oficiais estão
todos gravados e aí veio uma dúvida
muito grande o que nós exatamente
estamos fazendo por um mundo melhor
porque nossos olhos só nos volta só se
voltam para meus filhos meus netos meus
sobrinhos os filhos dos meus amigos e
não para criança pobre
a nossa constituição coitadinha
ela diz desde 1988 que é dever do estado
e da família e da sociedade em proteger
com prioridade absoluta à criança
adolescente dando lhe a educação
alimentação e 37 centro desde 88 a
constituição diz isso
um dia o sorriso de uma criança pobre e
tocou
você pode pensar mas então qual é a
solução se os governos não tomam
providências se os países não se
sensibilizam se a dinastia do mundo é a
dinastia do ter do egoísmo do dinheiro
a solução é aquela mesma da culpa
quando você parar de olhar pro outro e
apontar uma culpa você se olha no
espelho e aponta
e aí depois que você faz isso você
reflete o que eu posso fazer
nós temos que mudar mentalidades o
brasil desde que ele foi colonizado para
a nossa tristeza que a exploração sexual
de crianças e adolescentes faz parte da
nossa história
faz parte da nossa história quando
vieram os colonizadores de portugal
cerca de 200 homens navio e cinco
mulheres chamadas as órfãs do rei para
satisfazer os 200 homens
faz parte da nossa história quando
branco porto grego e português vêm
colonizar crie um sistema de feudos ea
partir desse sistema de feudos o que foi
que ele fez
bastava ele se tem alguma necessidade
sexual e descontar em crianças e
adolescentes negras sabe qual era o
ditado na época do brasil colônia
nada melhor para depurar um branco se
fico do que uma adolescente negra vg
o que você tem feito quando o sorriso de
uma criança vai te tocar vai tocar a nós
como pessoas como seres humanos
a maior grandiosidade de um ser humano
não é o que ele tem é o que ele é
é quando ele se olha no espelho sem um
terno sem uma gravata sem uma jóia cara
completamente nus sem máscaras
e diz 'não eu fiz alguma coisa ainda que
pouca
então qual é a frase que resumir 'ia
este sentimento é perfeito a frase josé
saramago é perfeita
se tens um coração de ferro bom proveito
mas o meu é de carne e sangra todos os
dias e nunca deixará de sangrar e quanto
uma criança e ver que vender o seu corpo
para se prostituir
a cena da mina através de me socou tanto
que eu pedi a um artista para desenhar
lá eu queria que um dia os policiais não
fossem atrás de crianças para resgatá
las para brincar com elas
eu queria que um dia a gente pudesse
abrir a janela e pudesse dar um erro
infantil porque no nosso jardim teria
crianças de todos os credos de todas as
cores com uma coisa em comum todas a
brincar reflitam
vamos construir um mundo melhor não é
obrigado